ich weiß nicht gesagt gar nicht wo ich
anfangen soll vor einigen Tagen haben
sich diese fünf Menschen zusammengetan
um mit diesem Tauchboot was wirklich
basically einfach nur nicht
zertifizierter Kühlschrank ist ich meine
for real jedes U-Boot oder Tauchboot
oder keine Ahnung was hat Sonne Technik
wisst ihr was die für eine Technik dort
hatten
das ist ein 30 Euro Logitech Controller
der mittlerweile bei Amazon sogar nur
noch einen Stern weil der alle Idioten
sowas drunter schreiben wie der
disconnected sich immer wenn du ihn am
meisten brauchst irgendwie geht's mit
dem Controller nur runter aber hoch geht
nicht mehr ich habe ihn gekauft und mein
U-Boot zu steuern und jetzt bin ich
verloren bitte helft mir und dann alle
unter euch die noch nichts von dieser
ganzen U-Boot Titanic taucht Tragödie
mitbekommen haben Mond
oder die nutzt wahrscheinlich einfach
nur Instagram Reals
diese fünf Personen haben eine viertel
Millionen Dollar in die Hand genommen um
mit dieser Dose
gesteuert von diesen 30 € Controller
guck mal mit Materialien von Alibaba
bestellt
als Ballast haben die alte baurohre
genommen das ist genauso wie wenn Sandra
jetzt sagen würde hey Luca ich baue mir
ein Flugzeug das Flugzeug sieht dann so
aus und damit will sie allen Ernstes vom
Kölner Dom bis nach Bielefeld fliegen
es ist klar dass das nicht gut gehen
kann und das haben auch alle gesagt
entweder im Vorhinein können
oder jetzt auch vor drei Tagen als die
Suchaktion anfängt
[Musik]
Spiegel TV hat mit einem deutschen
Experten auf dem Gebiet Tauchgänge mit
Tauchbooten etc gesprochen und selbst
der hat gesagt das kann funktionierendes
Ortungssystemen
ein wenig Geld mehr hätte man
möglicherweise und ich bin der fast
leider sicher diesen Unfall vermeiden
und das aller krasseste ist dass diese
Büchse ja auch nur ausgelegt ist für
Tauchgänge bis zu 1.500 Meter
wisst ihr wie tief die Titanic liegen
über 3000 Meter tief das ist fast
zehnmal der Eiffelturm nach unten
was auch übrigens ganz viele glaube ich
nicht so ganz verstanden haben die sind
nicht gestorben weil sie keine Luft mehr
hatten da unten sondern weil diese Red
Bull Dose in der sie drin waren
implodiert ist durch den ganzen Druck
wird die einfach zusammengezogen wie so
eine Dose die man zusammendrückt die
fünf Insassen haben all diese Risiken in
Kauf genommen weil sie unbedingt die
Titanic noch mal sehen wollten
Bro kauft euch doch einfach diese Apple
Vision pro für 3000 Euro dann habt ihr
die volle Erfahrung for real Freunde ich
mache dieses Video hier nicht weil ich
mich über den Tod von fünf Personen
lustig machen möchte um Gottes Willen
jedes Menschenleben was von uns geht ist
ein verlorenes Menschenleben stimmen wir
uns auch alle gegenseitig zu es ist
einfach nur ihre skurril dass die
Medienlandschaft und wirklich auch meine
komplette tiktok for you Patch ist voll
mit Sachen dazu dass sich alles mediale
Interesse auf dieses Unglück bezieht das
wird Millionen von Geldern ausgegeben
werden um die zu finden da wurde eine
Belohnung ausgesetzt von 100 Millionen
Dollar wenn man die findet
[Musik]
liveon hat die auch einfach direkt
gefunden deswegen gibt's in die Ofen und
sogar taylor Swift ist nach diesem
U-Boot tauchen gegangen
das geht sogar bis in Minecraft über oh
mein Gott
[Musik]
Level 104
Bro ist hat sogar bei Super Mario
Anklang gefunden
[Musik]
und auch bei Spongebob
und ich glaube von Real der einzige der
von dieser ganzen Tragödie profitiert
ist Netflix die lenken sich gerade die
Finger die denken schon also Titel wie
Wettlauf gegen die Zeit
Briefchen Leonardo DiCaprio macht schon
zum Casting allerdings mal bei Seite ich
glaube wir sind uns alle einig dass man
über fünf verstorbene Personen nicht
lachen sollte um Gottes Willen das
möchte ich auch gar nicht bewirken die
Sache ist nur dass ich wirklich die
Leute verstehen kann die sich über die
Art und Weise des Todes lustig machen
weil alle Zeichen standen auf Alarm das
sollte man nicht machen zum
zertifizierten kühlschrank mit einem
Logitech Controller sorry was wolltet
ihr sonst für ein Controller nehmen hier
oder hier ein Patrick Controller oder
den hier oder den hier oder in Gamecube
Controller wollte vielleicht eine
Kettensäge Controller machen und
schicken Nuggets oder noch viel besser
eine Fernbedienung
no no no ich habe mir gestern Abend eine
Menge Gedanken zu dieser ganzen Tragödie
gemacht und euch ja dann auch auf
Instagram gefragt ob ihr denkt dass es
eine sinnvolle Entscheidung wäre ein
Video dazu zu machen und wie ich euch ja
gerade auch eingeblendet habe hat
wirklich ein Großteil von euch gesagt ja
bitte mach ein Video zu dieser ganzen
Geschichte wie geht es nicht in erster
Linie darum hier irgendwie die
auszulachen wie man in so blöd sein kann
und danach unten zu fahren die Toten
Ruhe zu stören und sich zu denken hey
komm diese Dose die überhaupt nicht
dafür gemacht ist wir steuern die immer
weiter runter immer weiter runter darum
geht's mir gar nicht in erster Linie in
erster Linie geht's nämlich darum dass
überhaupt keine Aufmerksamkeit weil
dieses ganze mediale Interesse sich nur
auf diese U-Boot Tragödie bei der
Titanic gerichtet hat das gar keine
Aufmerksamkeit auf die Tragödie im
Mittelmeer gelenkt wurde
da sind hunderte Menschen ertrunken
bei einem Flüchtlingsboot
vor der Küste Griechenlands
Leute aus Afghanistan und anderen
umliegenden Ländern dort haben Schutz
gesucht in Europa Kriegsflüchtlinge
es wurden glaube ich bisher 80 90
leichten gefunden aber hunderte weitere
dort sind gestorben
und ich weiß es ist mittlerweile gefühlt
schon Alltag ist es ist gang und gäbe
und alle unter uns ich mich eingenommen
wir sind alle abgestumpft was dort unten
passiert natürlich ist man Tragödien
geil natürlich konzentriert sich die
ganze mediale Welt auf dieses U-Boot
dahin ich habe mehrere Freunde von mir
gestern Abend gefragt mit denen ich mich
dazu unterhalten habe in Gruppen etc ey
der das Mittel mehr mitbekommen was war
da
alle wusste aber direkt Bescheid wenn du
gesagt hast Titan Schlauchboot aber was
dahinten abgeht das ist viel krasser und
man sollte einfach die Möglichkeiten die
Ressourcen das Geld bündeln und
langfristiger denken man hätte so viel
mehr Menschen leben retten können jedes
Menschenleben ist es wert gerettet zu
werden aber wenn man die Kräfte
aufgebracht hätte im Mittelmeer wo Leute
nicht freiwillig gesagt haben hey komm
wir gehen auf ein viel zu beladenes
asylboot ins Mittelmeer rein um Schutz
zu suchen in Europa vom Krieg nee das
einzige was freiwillig war weil die
Aktion von diesen fünf egoistischen
Forscher die sich gedacht haben kommen
wir schauen uns mal die Titanic und dann
und wissen eigentlich schon dass wir
sterben werden weil das Boot nicht dafür
ausgelegt ist
wenn man einfach ein bisschen nachdenken
würde
das ist halt die Sache die mich so
stutzig macht und das ist der Grund
warum ich dieses Video mache das ein
paar Leute auch mal lernen ey
es geht nicht nur um die Sachen wo die
ganzen das ganze mediale Interesse drauf
ist sondern auch mal anderweitig denken
auch mal auf andere Sachen aufmerksam
machen natürlich ist das Schicksal
dieser fünf weißen Männer die da runter
zu Titanic tauchen wollten viel
ungewöhnlicher und für uns viel
spannender als das nächste
Flüchtlingsboot was untergegangen ist
mit den Leuten da aus Afghanistan
Pakistan Syrien wo auch immer her da hat
man gar keine Beziehung zu Titanic krass
Sensation geil aber das wir als Menschen
als Individuen entscheiden hey wem wir
Hilfe geben das hängt von Empathie und
von gefühlter Nähe
das ist riskant in unser Blick auf diese
dauerkrisen die ist ja leider wirklich
sind im Mittelmeer in unser Blick
einfach rationaler wäre und
langfristiger orientiert wenn man den
Umgang damit einfach mit einer Strategie
ausrichten würde dann geht es wirklich
deutlich weniger Tote und deutlich mehr
Hilfe
[Musik]
besser als ich glaube ich beende das
Video hier
es war für mich eh schon eine harte
Überwindung dass sie aufzunehmen weil
ich eigentlich sehr sehr selten
politisch werden möchte auf meinem Kanal
und ist heute einfach unvermeidbar war
meine tiktok for youpad war die letzten
zwei drei Tage voll mit diesem Thema
überall in den Medien ich bin im Gym es
läuft da auf dem Fernsehen ich rede mit
Leuten jeder spricht mich darauf an ich
gehe am ans Handy da sind Nachrichten
ich gehe auf tikt oder ist es da das
Thema kommt nicht um einen rum
deswegen was mir wichtig dieses Video zu
machen das ganze Thema zusammenzufassen
und zu sagen worauf es wirklich ankommt
denn nur weil da fünf Menschen gestorben
sind und das ganze median Interesse
darauf es heißt es nicht dass irgendwo
anders gerade alles super läuft es gibt
überall Probleme auf der Welt und ich
weiß dass dieses Video hier überhaupt
nichts bewirken wird aber wenn wir jetzt
alle in unserem Kopf drin haben und mal
so ein bisschen schauen okay ist das
wirklich jetzt gerade relevant da sind
fünf reiche Leute die sich denken oh
Titanic für Millionen Dollar hier ist
weil ich davon ausgeht egal wir fahren
runter BAM das geht schief alle stützen
sich darauf aber im Mittelmeer man kann
das ist vermeidbar im Mittelmeer man
kann einfach wenn man was ist
ich könnte mich wirklich in Rage reden
ich beende das besser hier an der Stelle
soll einfach nur so ein kleiner denk
Anschluss sein
meine Gedanken einfach runter gequatscht
und da wir jetzt mittlerweile schon seit
einem Monat keine Podcast folge mir
hochgeladen haben
mache ich das jetzt hier im Youtube
Video macht einen schönen Tag haut rein